I'm a geologist by training I do a lot
of heathered climate reconstruction
using corals and deep sea sediments I
work primarily in Fiji in Indonesia
Samoa Tonga South Pacific we
reconstructed intermediate water
temperature change in the Pacific
intermediate waters are between roughly
five a hundred and a thousand meters
down using sediment cores from Indonesia
which we collected in 2003 with my
colleagues say a Rosenthal and Dalia
oppo and what it shows is that the
intermediate wires have been cooling
over the last 10,000 years about two
degrees of cooling which is a large
degree of cooling up until about 1600 or
so we call a little ice age and since
then they started warming slightly
what's interesting about this work is
that intermediate waters today have been
warming quite a lot in the last 50 years
and we know they've been we can measure
this with thermometers and the rate of
warming today is about 15 times what it
was never in the past in the last 10,000
years so the oceans axis does act as a
large sort of capacitor you might say
they absorb heat and a release heat and
seem to buffer Earth's global climate
system so that's what's new but our
results is this whole temporal context
for the most recent warming of
intermediate waters and the other piece
of the puzzle is that the sediments in
Indonesia accumulate very rapidly
because when you're always land masses
and that allows us to get more samples
per time going down core whereas a lot
of sediments everywhere else in the
Pacific are very slowly or they're in
chord they've been dissolved partially
by corrosive bottom waters so you can't
just do this everywhere we can only and
we did it able here because of the
unique sediment record there
I do a lot of paler climate
reconstruction using corals on different
timescales the corals are quite
fascinating because they have annually
annual rings in them and like a tree
which grows out these corals grow
upwards and some of the cores we have
have annual rings that go back four or
five hundred years so a 400 year old
coral would be about 4 meters high loans
we work on and so we collect the core
out of the top
we cut the core in half we slab it and
x-ray it and they grow about a
centimeter a year and we to give you
some idea of how we work in the lab we
sample these every millimeter a little
drill so 4 meter core control every
millimeter would be four thousand
samples and we can analyze about 30
samples a day in the lab so 4000 divided
by 30 is a lot of days in the lab and
it's such a huge amount of lab time and
money to analyze these things but at the
end of the day the the fact you have
this annual resolve chronology is
enormous because it allows you to ask
all sorts of questions about climate
variability and in terms of El Nino
events and century scale trends and
correlating from one to another you
don't have that luxury using deep sea
sediments because the age models are not
accurate enough we're trying to use
corals as a to extend the ins smell
record because we can calibrate them
against instrumental data in the last 30
to 40 - 50 years you might be surprised
how little instrumental data there is
actually going back in before 1960
during the world wars there's almost
none none well water temperature data
World War two and one so we're trying to
extend the instrumental record with the
coral records because we can cross
calibrate them back in time and so our
longest record published so far goes
back to 1607 from Fiji and the once we
finish the Samoa record I'll probably go
back and 1500s